TIM BRAY: I'm Tim Bray.
I'm here to talk about
identity today.
Thank you for all coming out.
I do appreciate it.
Start with some good news
and some bad news.
It's like this.
If somebody comes and wants to
use your site or your service
and they get logged in real
easy, real fast, no problems,
they don't think, wow,
those guys really
have their act together.
I love them.
I'm going to go back there.
And if they wake up in the
morning and there's no news
story about how you got hacked
and lost 100,000 passwords
that they also used for their
bank accounts, they don't
think, oh, gosh, this guy is
taking good care of me.
But the other way around
is not so good.
If they come to your site and
there's a problem logging in,
then they won't.
They'll just go somewhere else
that has their act together on
logging in.
And if they do wake up in the
morning and discover that you
lost control of their passwords,
and the bad guys
have them, that's a really
bad position you
don't want to be in.
So that's what identity
is like.
Identity is this thing where
if you perform perfectly,
nobody notices it.
And if you screw up, you
know your name is mud.
And that's, historically, the
way identity has been.
However, I think we can maybe do
a little better than that.
For today, I'm going to try
and mix some good news in
among the bad news.
And maybe the most important
piece of good news is going to
be that we are trying really
hard to make it easier for you
to do the right thing
with less work.
So today, I bring
you "less work."
On top of that, we also have a
few developer-oriented goodies
that are worth looking at.
So it is true.
There are sometimes good things
to be found in identity.
And we'll talk about them.
I'd like to encourage everybody
to leave some feedback.
At Google, we try and be
a data-driven company.
But sometimes, it
doesn't work.
And I know we haven't actually
done that great a job in the
past to track people's
results.
We're really trying to do
a lot better this year.
It's easy.
You got your I/O app.
There's a QR code there.
It should not take you
more than about 30
seconds to rate the talk.
Please do that.
And if you all do, then
ideally next year's
show will be better.
Now, if you've looked at the
program, you will have noticed
that there are a whole lot
of talks about identity.
And presumably, you care since
you came to this one.
And so one of the goals for
today's session is to give you
a feeling as to which of these
might actually be most
interesting and appropriate
for you and
help meet your needs.
So we'll try and revisit
this at the end.
Now, if you take a close look at
the other sessions on here,
you will observe that a lot of
them are about Google+ Sign-In
There is no doubt whatsoever
that the Google+ team sees
part of what they are doing
as an identity ecosystem.
They have been doing a huge
amount of work on that.
And I'm going to give you a
feeling for why that is.
So I'm going to try to do that
during the course of this
session today.
So today is not really
going to be a
technology session per se.
I want to spend most
of my time--
oh, there will be code.
I warn you there will be code.
I want to spend most of my
time talking about which
things you might choose, what
tools you might want to use to
approach them.
But I do want to talk a little
bit about the technology.
We have made a fairly
substantial bet here at Google
on the use of the Open Auth
2.0 standard and,
increasingly, the OpenID Connect
standard which is
layered on top of OAuth 2.
Once again, bad news.
This is some seriously
complex shit.
It's big and hairy and kind of
hard to learn and understand.
And I don't want to spend today
talking about how it all
works and pull it all apart as
easily because that could take
a lot of time.
However, to help simplify
things, I have prepared a
short simplified diagram of the
important components of
OAuth 2 and how they
fit together.
Here it is.
Seriously, it's a problem.
I've been public speaking
for a lot of years.
And I've spoken in
most places.
And I've had the unusual
experience in recent times of
having talks rejected by
conferences because they had
"identity" in the title.
And I think they were afraid
that I was going to stand up
and talk about cryptography
algorithms for the whole time.
And I'm going to try
and avoid that.
I am, however, going to talk a
little bit about a couple of
pieces of technology--
they're associated
with this stuff.
And I want to talk about
them because I
think they're important.
And also, because as I learn
them over the course of recent
time, speaking as an
internet geek, I
thought, hey, that's clever.
That's interesting.
So I thought you might find
it interesting, too.
So that is an ID token.
That is an access token.
And you take that great, big,
complicated intricate piece of
OAuth machinery.
And you crank it and you crank
it and you crank it.
And this is what comes
out at the end.
It is just a string.
It is designed so that it
doesn't have magic characters.
And you could put in the URL.
But aside from that, it
is just a string.
And the way you use
it is like that.
So you go and you do an ordinary
HTTP transaction.
And you send that access
token along.
And that's all the
authentication you have to do.
So that particular thing is
fetching somebody's basic
Google+ profile.
And you may notice that in the
URL, there's nothing that
identifies whose
profile it is.
That's OK because that's wrapped
up in the token.
So these things are opaque.
You can't read them.
Your app is not expected to look
inside them and discover
anything in particular.
But it turns out, it's
not secret at all.
So let's unpack the access token
and see what's inside.
So Google has what's called
a token info endpoint.
And you can get out with
good old curl.
So if I go and de-reference
that access token--
I cut it off so it wouldn't
fill up the whole slide--
and you can see it says
a bunch of things.
It says what user it was issued
to and what they asked
for and a couple of other
interesting things.
It also tells you that it
expires in 3,370 seconds.
When we issue these things,
they're good for
more or less an hour.
And this thing has 50-odd
minutes yet to live.
So access tokens are not
hard to understand.
They are bearer tokens.
They're like $100 bill.
They are good.
They are a currency in
and of themselves.
You send it along.
This grants server, after
looking at that, will grant
the right to access the person
identified's information as if
they were that person.
So the takeaways are
not that complex.
I mean, the most important thing
is that as I've just
shown you, there's nothing
very secret about this.
So as you use them and transmit
them around the
network, you must, must, must
always use HTTPS, TLS.
You must never ever, ever
transmit these over an
unencrypted connection.
Now, of course, you're already
doing that, right?
Everybody using HTTPS
for everything.
Right?
Good.
These things are actually
remarkably powerful.
And you can abuse them in ways
that sound surprising, but are
actually sensible.
So for example, suppose
I have a mobile app.
There's videos being uploaded
to somewhere
in my Google Drive.
And it wants to retrieve a
thumbnail of the video that's
been uploaded.
And you really don't want to
download a 30-second video,
load it into your mobile
device's memory, and process
it to extract a thumbnail.
So why don't you get an access
token to access Google Drive,
ship it up to your own back-end
server in the cloud
somewhere-- it's a big
meaty server--
have it access Google Drive on
your behalf, compute the
thumbnail and send it back?
So it's transferable.
I've taken my transferable
write.
Send it off to the cloud.
Let the cloud work on it.
Get it back.
You could conceivably
do it the other way.
You can get an access token in
a web app and send it down to
the mobile to do something
clever with it.
Go crazy.
This is a power tool.
You cut your foot off with it,
don't say I didn't warn you.
But you can do a lot of clever
things with these.
So those are access tokens.
And they are key component
in OAuth 2.
Now, on top of OAuth 2 is
built OpenID Connect.
And it has a refinement
on access
tokens called ID tokens.
There is an ID token.
Isn't it pretty?
Now, if you're really sharp-eyed
and look closely at
it, you may observe that it
has two dots in there.
An ID token has a lot more
interesting stuff inside than
a basic access token.
So the way you unpack
it is this.
It turns out that the part
before the first dot is
actually just base64 JSON.
So you can unpack it
and look at it.
And it identifies what the
cryptographic signature is.
It says this algorithm and
then a key, which is
identified as ad2a50.
And then that last
part after the
second dot is the signature.
And what's being signed is
the payload in between.
So you know the algorithm?
You know the key identifier?
So what you do is you go to
Google's well-known certs
endpoint, retrieve the currently
active certificates.
And if you look closely, the
second one is identified by
ad2a50, yadda, yadda.
And so you would use that cert
to validate that the signature
on the token is correct.
And you can be really, really
sure the token came from
Google because, of course, we
signed it with our private key
and you checked it publicly.
Now, when I say, you retrieve
and you do, I'm not suggesting
for a second that you should
actually write the code to do
all this crypto stuff.
And you don't need to because
these tokens, which are called
JavaScript or JSON web tokens,
are a well-known thing.
Every popular programming
library in the world has a
built-in validator for it.
So you just hand it over
to the validator.
And it'll go fetch
the right cert.
The other nice thing, it turns
out that these certs are only
rolled over once a day
or so, and so the
library caches them.
And you can actually validate
the token very fast
statically, right there
on your machine.
So now, what's inside?
So after we've validated using
the front cert and the back
cert, you look inside,
and here's what's
inside the ID token.
And that's pretty interesting.
It tells you that it was issued
by Google, that the
subject was this long number
that's a unique identifier in
the identity ecosystem, that
it was presented to an
authorized party, azp, which
actually represents, in this
case, the Android client
who got the ID token.
Some other interesting fields.
It's got this thing called an
audience, which means this is
the holder of the resource that
this thing is aimed at.
And so this is actually
a very interesting
and powerful thing.
It is a self-contained,
cryptographically signed
statement, verifiable
everywhere, that Google issued
this, that Google really, really
thought that that user
identified in it was
authenticated to some devices,
some browser, somewhere, and
it was aimed at some
particular audience.
Like an access token, there's
nothing secret.
I'll refrain from shouting must
must, must, must at you.
But you really got to send this
over to HTTPS, please.
You got to do that.
These things are really,
really useful.
Let me give you a little
imaginary scenario.
There's this website called
FlightAware that offers the
status of any flight that's
in the air, anywhere.
And there's another service
called Tripit.
It's a personal travel
manager.
Now, I'm going to describe the
scenario that these guys
aren't actually doing,
but should.
Suppose you go to FlightAware.
And it could just go and talk
to Tripit and find out what
flights you're going to be on.
And it just automatically
show you the
status of those flights.
Wouldn't that be great?
Well, with this, you
could do it.
You could take your ID token.
Ship it off to one
of the back-ends.
And assuming FlightAware and
Tripit had a deal, they could
look inside the ID token,
validate it, and say, oh yeah,
this really is a token that was
issued to this person with
the intent of it being
seen by Tripit.
And if Tripit and FlightAware
had a deal, they could switch
it back and forth, each side
could validate what it is and
who it was sent to, and no
further requirements for
anybody to type a password or
do anything like that it.
It would all just
work magically.
So that's just one scenario.
Put your minds to work.
And if you have portable chunks
of identification,
there are all sorts of
magic things that you
potentially do with it.
So why don't you just go out and
do some of those things?
The APIs for getting these
things are all fully
documented.
And I'll give you a little bit
more guidance about how to
navigate through
them later on.
Next thing.
Now, let's go back
to the bad news.
The problem is that these things
do not really have a
good reputation.
They have a reputation for
being hard to understand.
being arcane and hard to
understand.
And unfortunately, the people
who've been presenting them to
the world have got up on stage
and talked about ITF graphs
and cryptography algorithms,
and Redirect URIs, and
implicit flows and also the
stuff that you, guys, really
should not have to care about.
So they've got probably
a bit more of a bad
rap than they deserve.
The good news I have for you
today is that the libraries
that are generally available
pretty well cover it.
The amount of stuff you actually
have to understand
about how this stuff works
ranges between slim and, more
or less, zero.
It is, generally speaking, a
best practice for you to use
one of these libraries rather
than code it up yourself just
because identity is so
important, and the penalties
for getting it wrong
are so bad.
And in particular, I'm going to
plug the use of the Google+
Sign-In library.
But most of these
things have the
authentication stuff built in.
And as you can see, they are
available for pretty well any
popular programming platform
that you can imagine.
So use the libraries--
well, except for if you don't
want to use the libraries.
There is a certain proportion
of the population like, for
example, me, that are REST
bigots and actually like
working down close to
the HTTP level.
So if you are the kind of person
who likes doing HTTP
flows and likes composing JSON
and sending it over the wire
and parsing the JSON and gets
back and fiddling with the
HTTP headers, well,
that's OK, too.
In fact, everything I'm going to
describe today is perfectly
accessible at the raw
HTTP flow level.
Now, that has a huge
disadvantage that you don't
get all the helpful codes built
into libraries and all
that debugging and so on.
On the other hand, it
has the upside.
You don't have to learn
the library.
And for some people, it has the
upside that you don't have
to link library into your code,
which for some people,
it is a really big code.
So if you understand what's on
the screen now, you're a
candidate to be that
kind of person.
If you like what you see, you
are almost certainly the kind
of person who might like
to do it this way.
So if you want to do
that, go nuts.
We're not going to
try and stop you.
I'm also not going to say
anything further in this talk
to help you because that's OK.
Because that kind of person is
OK with going and reading the
docs and figuring out the
headers and manipulating the
HTTP flows and so on.
So that door always
remains open.
So let's go back to a high level
and talk about what we
can actually do.
There are two basic things that
we can do with identity
technologies.
One of them being actual
authorization, which is the
process of saying, OK,
I checked that this
is really Tim Bray.
And, yeah, we've given Tim Bray
the right to access the
Google Drive.
So go ahead and access
the Google Drive.
That's authorization.
The other is authentication
where we don't really care
about any particular API.
All we want is for Google to
say, yeah, I've authenticated.
And that really is Tim Bray
there on that mobile device or
on that browser or whatever.
So let's talk about how we
go about doing that.
So now, I'm going to switch
to my browser here.
And this is the thing they
showed during the keynote.
And let's just look at
it again briefly.
So this is Fancy.
Amazingly, it's same machine
that was on there in the
keynote, huh?
Anyhow, you hit Sign In.
And it says, oh, who do you
want to sign in with--
Facebook, Google, or Twitter?
I'm going to sign with Google.
And it comes up here
and says--
they went by this awfully fast
during the keynote-- say, OK,
let's do a full-blown
social sign-in here.
Not only am I going to log you
in and tell Fancy that, yeah,
this really is Tim.
We're going to say, I'd like to
ask you to authorize Fancy
to see who your friends are on
Google and maybe even to tell
them about some of the things
you did on Fancy.
And you get very, very
fine-grained control there
about who exactly the Fancy
app you'd share with when
you're using it on Google.
By the way, this is
not required.
You don't have to go through
all the social stuff.
You can just do a pure naked
login saying, yeah,
this is Tim, bye.
But this is the full-blown
social login.
And it's got the other nice
characteristic that when you
accept it, it'll come along and
say, oh, do you also want
to install, as they showed, the
mobile app on the device?
And when it does that, the app
on the device will come up
magically being already logged
in to the right account in the
right place.
So it's pretty slick.
So that is what Google+
really buys you.
I'll just show you a much
simpler example.
This is the Ruby Quickstart
example for Google+ Sign-In.
It's really tiny.
It's a couple of hundred lines
of Ruby and a couple of
hundred lines of JavaScript,
both of which are mostly just
boilerplate code.
And this is the simplest
possible thing.
You just sign in.
And it says, OK, know your name,
sign in, accept, boom.
And now, I'm signed in.
And it shows that it knows my
picture, my name, something
about my biography, and has
access to the information
about who is in my circles.
So that's just the bare-bone
social login.
So the question that comes up
is, what do you actually have
to do to accomplish that?
And the answer is
not very much.
You have to put a bunch of
JavaScript in your HTML,
almost all of which
is boilerplate.
It just comes up.
You can download it out of our
Git repository or wherever.
And put it in your
own client ID.
And you notice that this is the
actual chunk of HTML that
produces the Sign-in button.
It's got both an
ID and a class.
So it's very, very easy to wire
into your own page design
in a way that shouldn't
be obtrusive.
Now, this being the Ruby
example, here's the Ruby code
in the back-end that actually
retrieves that list of
people's pictures and displays
it on the screen.
And you'll notice if you look
at the bottom third of that,
they actually went and used the
built-in understanding of
the Google+ API that is built
into our Ruby client library
and just said, go, get me
a list of people and run
through them all.
Now, once again, if you're a
REST hard ass, at this point
you can say, no, no,
I don't want that.
I'm just going to go do a get on
that URL, and get the list
of people back as JSON.
I manipulate it myself.
That's fine.
There's really true independent
pieces of
technology working here-- the
stuff at the top that shows
the actual authorization stuff
going through the Google
identity provider and the stuff
at the bottom, which is
the Ruby Google+ library.
You could use either
or both or neither.
You can put them together
any way you want.
Now, you noticed that when we
logged in to Fancy, it asked
us to download a mobile app.
And when it logged into
my app, it didn't.
So if we wanted it to download
a mobile app, we would have
had to change our JavaScript,
thus.
You put in one more argument,
which is the package name of
the mobile app in
the Play Store.
And so here's a secret.
I did that.
I did put that package
name in.
And that's a real package name,
a real mobile app that I
really published and that's
really in the Play Store.
And it didn't work.
It didn't download.
So I went looking
around for why.
And it turns out that if
you looked at the app I
referenced, it's just a little
geeky identity sample testing
app that only a few identity
geeks in the
world have ever run.
And nobody has ever
reviewed it.
And it has hardly
any downloads.
And it turns out that there's
a quality threshold.
So the sign-in process will
decline to install your app
unless it meets a certain
threshold quality, which,
well, this one unfortunately
doesn't.
And it just quietly said,
no, I'm not going to
install that for you.
So the takeaway is that using
these libraries, you invest a
relatively small
amount of work.
And you get, I think, a fairly
substantially large amount of
functionality and
user experience.
And the security is good.
You can be really very confident
the logins aren't
being spoofed.
Let's talk about the logging in
process at a lower level.
I mean, we're all used to
seeing this these days.
And the reason is that many,
many developers all over the
world put up websites and they
think, OK, well, that means I
have to be in the password
business.
And my main mission
here today--
more important than
any other--
is to start begging you, people,
to get out of the
password business.
So I know you think you maybe
have to store passwords.
So if you're doing that, of
course, you're storing them in
a salted, hashed, encrypted
form, right?
And you're using a modern hash
function that's not easily
reversible, right?
And you've got all sorts of
automatic monitors in place.
So when somebody's been logging
in from the same
Macintosh in Toronto for 17
months and suddenly shows up
from a Windows machine in
Vladivostok, you're going to
notice that and react, right?
And you've got a two-factor
authentication system in
place, so you can help with
that situation, right?
And you've got some sort of a
simplified log-in mechanism
for mobiles so they don't have
to type a cryptographically
strong password into
a mobile device,
which nobody can, right?
And you are paying for help
desk, so that when people have
trouble logging in, they
can call up, right?
Wrong!
Don't do those things.
It's the wrong way to go.
The risk is high.
The benefit is low.
And it's seductively easy
because, whether you're using
Django or PHP or Rails or Java
or whatever, there's always a
user authentication module
you can just download.
Oh, here, I'll just install
this gem or bring in this
no-JS thing, it'll take care of
users and passwords for me.
Yeah, it'll probably work OK.
But it means you own the awesome
responsibility of
being a good steward of
other people's data.
That's a bad place to be.
You don't want to be there.
And so I've searched Google
for password rules.
And that's the top match.
I won't name the--
I won't shame the famous 500
name company whose password
rules they are.
But there's another good reason
you want to get out of
the password business, which
is that everybody today is
using more online services than
they were using last year
at this time.
And we just know that next year
at this time, they're
going to be using more.
And if every one of those
services all over the internet
insist on having their own
authentication mechanism, that
means people have to remember
a larger number of passwords
and authentications
every year.
And so, they don't.
They either use really weak
passwords, thereby making it
easier for the bad guys.
Or they use the same password
for their bank and their goth
music fan club, which may not
have quite equal standards of
security and maintenance.
If you are forcing people to do
this, you are peeing in the
swimming pool.
You are being a bad citizen
of the internet.
You are decreasing security,
globally.
An internet with bad security
is bad for your business.
It's bad for Google's
business.
And way more important than
that, it's bad for the people
who are trying to use the
internet to live their lives.
So you really, really need to
start figuring out how to get
out of the password business.
Now, that means that if you are
starting something new,
just don't get in,
you'll be OK.
If you're already and have a
million passwords on file, you
have a harder problem, but you
need to start working now on
figuring out how to solve it.
Now, I keep throwing around the
term, "the bad guys," who
are going to try and steal
this password,
and make life difficult.
And we treat them
in the abstract.
We all know there's bad
guys out there.
Well, here they are.
That's kind of small print and
it's in Cyrillics, so you
wouldn't be able to
read it anyhow.
But it is a list of passwords
and hacked accounts for sale
from a website.
And you can get accounts
on Mail.ru, Yandex.ru,
Hotmail.com, Outlook.com,
and so on.
When the guys at Google look
at this, they break out the
champagne because, as opposed
to the tens of thousands of
other things, you'll notice
that Gmail, there are only
eight stolen accounts
for sale.
And they are approximately ten
times as expensive as stolen
accounts from elsewhere.
Now, let's be fair.
I didn't have room to put
the whole thing on here.
But if you scroll down here on
the bad guys' site, you will
discover one more internet site
that has dramatically
lower availability
and higher cost.
And that's Facebook.
So Facebook and Google, it's
fair to say, are doing a
pretty good job of handling
users' identities.
And that's another reason why
you should go around and
choose your partners
carefully.
So I'm going to say, let's
outsource your identity.
Do not own your own passwords.
So these here is the kind of
screens we are starting to see
a whole lot of all over
the internet.
So what we have here
is Pinterest,
OpenTable, and Tripit.
And in each case, you have
multiple different options to
log in with.
So the jargon is like this.
People, like Facebook and Google
and Microsoft and Yahoo
and so on, are identity
providers, IDPs.
And the people who use
them are called
relying parties, RPs.
So you'll hear this jargon slung
around all the time--
RP and IDP.
If you're an RP, this means that
you are a good person.
You are not peeing in
the internet pool.
However, we are starting to have
a little bit of a scaling
problem, which is I don't think
many RPs would want to
jump into bed with
just one IDP.
So this kind of situation
is typical.
But those login screens are
already starting to
look kind of busy.
The term we use in the identity
community is "NASCAR
page" because it's like a NASCAR
race car, it has too
many stickers on it.
And it is not really
going to scale.
We're at the moment most people
are OK with Facebook
and Google or Facebook and
Twitter, Google and Twitter,
or whatever.
But I think we need a wide open
identity ecosystem so
that we can have multiple
identity providers competing
for people's business.
And it's just not enough
room on the page there.
And it's already the case that
if you're operating in certain
countries in the world, there
are very strong local identity
providers that you would want
to have on that page.
So let me show you
the alternative.
Let me just switch back
to my browser here.
And here, I have a small sample
application I wrote.
It's on the internet.
And it does one thing--
remembers your favorite color.
And when you go there, it
doesn't actually show you a
login page.
It shows you this thing.
This is called an
account chooser.
And even though it says
accountchooser.com, it's all
just stuff stored in
local storage.
This is a project of the OpenID
Foundation that's just
being rolled out.
And the idea is that instead of
signing in with a password,
I would just click, say,
OK, here's the
Facebook identity provider.
And I'll login to favcolor.
It's, oh, welcome, Tim Bray.
We know your favorite
color, which I've
logged therein before.
So Facebook did the
signing up.
And let's just change the
favorite color and make it a
nice blue color.
And I'll log out.
And, hey, that same email
address is also available at
Google account.
So I'll log in the same account
through Google rather
than Facebook.
See?
Remembers my new
favorite color.
One-click login.
This is what you
owe your users.
Actually, you owe them
more than that.
Let's me show what else
you owe them.
Now, here's another account,
my Gmail account.
Let's click on that one.
And it says, oh, here's Google
saying, oh, they
want to log you in.
Is that OK?
I'll say, yeah, OK, sure.
So it'll log me in.
And it says here something
different.
We don't know your
favorite color.
So we're picking
one at random.
That wasn't one-click login.
That was two-click sign up.
That website had never
seen me before.
Two clicks and it's created
an account, signed me up.
So keep an eye on the
Account Chooser.
This kind of technology is going
to be coming out from a
lot of directions.
The general idea is this is
some sort of an API that
maintains outside application
space, a list of the accounts
people like to log in with.
And your app calls the API.
And it gives you back
a data string.
Here's the email they
want to log in with.
Here's the IDP they
like to use.
Go nuts.
So let's go back to
the talk here.
So what I've been talking
about so far is what you
should be doing.
And I want to spend the rest of
my time, which there isn't
much of, talking about how
you should be doing it.
This is fairly conceptually
simple.
But I have been in the
identity group of
Google for a year now.
And I have to confess that it
has been a fairly steep hill
to climb for me to get
comfortable with the concepts
and tools and methods and
libraries and so on.
So what we've done is we've
tried to capture a lot of that
meta-knowledge and create this
new thing called the Google
Identity Cookbook, which we just
finished pushing an hour
or two ago.
And this is at that URL.
And it tries to be a
human-readable walk through
all the different identity
technologies we have at Google
and how you might want to
go about using them.
It does not actually contain
any samples or detailed
documentation because we
have loads and loads
and loads of that.
This tries to look at your
scenario and help you figure
out which applies to you.
I'm going to dip into
this a bit.
The first page that people are
mostly going to come to is
"Platforms" because I noticed
when I talk to people about
their identity problems, they
always begin with something
like, oh, I've got a PHP
program and I need to.
Or I'm trying to get at this
from iOS and I need to.
So that's the way programmers
tend to think.
They think in terms of the
platforms that they are
currently developing on.
So there's a lot of information
behind these links.
And basically, if you're writing
a native Android app
or a server-side web app or a
browser-centric JavaScript
app, we can take pretty
good care of you.
The libraries are there.
They're in good shape.
Plug them in.
And it just works.
You really should have
relatively little trouble
getting good results.
If you are writing native apps
in other platforms, things get
a little trickier.
Typically, to do the OAuth
flows, it means you have to
spin out a browser from your
native app, do the OAuth, and
get the result back from the
OAuth, and then you're good to
go, which sounds kind of icky.
It's actually not that bad.
But it's certainly
not as pleasant
as those other platforms.
In particular, we're not doing
a good enough job on iOS at
the moment, even
on Google Apps.
If you've got five Google Apps
on your iPhone, you're going
to end up typing your Google
password in five times, and
that sucks.
And so we're working on
all these things, and
we will make progress.
Once again, I wanted to come
back to this and say that when
you're speaking in terms of
platforms, another good reason
to use the Google+ Sign-In
stuff is, well, that.
Because Google+ Sign-In comes
with this incredibly
comprehensive set of libraries
and sample apps for any known
platform under the sun.
Having said that, I want to give
you another reason why I
think you should carefully
consider Google+ Sign-In.
And that is, that no
man is an island.
We have singletons in our
computer programming.
People aren't singletons.
The world we live in is, in
fact, in very large part
defined by the other people who
share our lives with us.
And I think that people, in
general, can enrich their
users' experience and provide
a higher level of service if
they bring a social dimension
to login.
The plural of identity
is society.
Did I mention that Mark
Zuckerberg's a billionaire?
Give it a good look.
No, it's not compulsory.
You can still use Google
identity technology without
using the Google+
Sign-In stuff.
But it is definitely the most
evolved piece of the puzzle.
Another thing I want to talk
about that I think is
important--
it's in the Cookbook, we talked
about quite a bit--
it's this whole notion of
"Roles." Sometimes, the
simplest case is when you're
operating on behalf of a human
and the human is right there
at the browser or at the
mobile device.
Everything gets very
easy then.
If they need to sign off
and approve anything,
well, there they are.
They can just do that.
In the worst case, if they
haven't logged in for too
long, they can even type
in a password.
But there are a lot of cases
where you want to do work on
behalf of people who
aren't there.
That turns out to be possible.
Along with those ID tokens and
access tokens that I showed
you at the beginning
of the talk?
There's a thing called
a refresh token.
You get one of those.
Now, you notice that access
tokens expire
after an hour or so.
A refresh token allows
you to get a new one.
And refresh tokens never
expire until they're
explicitly revoked
by the user.
So if you can give somebody a
refresh token, which the user
has to approve explicitly, then
they can operate forever
offline without consulting
the user.
Think about it.
It's often very valuable.
There's also the notion of
sometimes you're talking about
not a human identity,
but app identity.
And there is actually a kind
of thing in OAuth called a
service account where an app has
its own identity that can
act on its behalf.
And there are some security
issues that arise.
And we, at Google, are actually
kind of stingy.
We won't give out service
accounts for all of our APIs.
But for the ones that
we do, you might
want to check it out.
It might be really, really
useful for you.
Now, the other thing we talked
about that actually came out
in this keynote a bit this
morning was this whole notion
of cross-client single
sign-on.
And any developer, who is
sitting down to write an app,
is typically actually sitting
down to write a server-side
back-end and an Android app
and an iOS app and maybe a
Windows app and a BlackBerry
app or whatever.
The notion when an app
is one program, those
days are long gone.
And both the developer who's
writing this and the people
who are using it tend to think
of the whole thing as a
single, useful software
facility.
And so, in general, we want to
assume that when somebody is
granted access to some resource,
to one piece of the
puzzle, they probably should be
considered to have granted
the access to all the pieces
of the puzzle.
In particular, if somebody has
already typed in their
password to approve access to
your thing on their mobile, we
shouldn't make them do it
again on the website.
And this cross-client identity
is one of the big, big weapons
we have working for us now in
our war against passwords on
the internet.
And I thought this was such a
wonderful thing that I wanted
to have to show a picture of
unicorns and rainbows.
But Google Legal is really
fierce and they won't let you
show any images that you hadn't
paid for and licensed.
So I went to Google and typed in
"Creative Commons licensed
unicorns and rainbows."
And what do you know?
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
TIM BRAY: Isn't that special?
So it turns out, we have a
nice hook to hang this
cross-client stuff on.
It turns out, whenever you want
to use any of this OAuth
and OpenID-based stuff, you
have to register your app.
You have to register your app
at a thing called the Google
Developer API console.
And this is just part of OAuth,
you have to do this
whenever you're using OAuth.
And it turns out that
the unit of
registration is the project.
And a project has lots of
slots in it in which you
create different kinds
of clients--
a web client, a JavaScript
client, iOS client, and
Android client, maybe
multiple clients.
These things are called Client
IDs in the term of the art.
And they are identified by these
big, long, ugly strings.
But they're all identified as
being in the same project.
And access to this thing, being
able to update it, is
controlled by the developer's
account.
And they have to log into the
account to get access to the
console to do this.
And we consider that a pretty
strong proof point.
So our general belief is that
if you've authed against one
of these things, you've authed
against all of them.
And that's wonderful.
So specifically, there's
actually a page in our
developer documentation that
talks about how to do this.
And it's a little
bit complicated.
And you have to make some very
particular API calls to get
this to work.
But the machinery that goes
behind what Google+ did to get
all that stuff automatically
working-- you log in, you get
the app installed, it's
all pre-logged in--
it's generally available to you,
right down to the HTTP
flows level, if you want to
be a hard-ass about it.
There are three things we do.
The first is really easy
to understand.
You've already got an access
token for some particular API
on your web client and you ask
for it again on your mobile
device, you won't get
asked to approve it.
They'll just say OK, I'll
give you the access
token and vice versa.
That's really easy
to understand.
Now, the next one is sharing
identity around the network.
And the best one of all
is this permanent
offline access tricks.
So I'm going to talk about both
of those a little bit.
So this shared sign-on is
a very common scenario.
And if you've got a client app,
which probably most of
the people in the room do,
it has a server back-end.
Even the most brain-dead simple
game probably needs to
persist and share high
scores, right?
So you have some sort of
a server back-end.
And you're talking to it
probably over a RESTful
interface over HTTPS.
And the question arises,
who am I talking to?
The server back-end needs
to know whose data is
being sent up there.
And it would be really, really,
really lame to ask
them to type their password in
on the mobile app just so they
could save stuff back
to the server.
And you don't want to save their
password and send it
over to the network.
That's very, very bad.
So it turns out what you can
do is use ID tokens.
ID tokens make the slickest
possible solution to this.
You get the ID token
on the client.
And when you ask for the
ID token, you have to
say who it's for.
So if you say it's for your
back-end, and if you're mobile
app and your back-end are in the
same project, we'll just
give you the ID token.
It won't prompt for approval or
anything because you're all
part of the same project.
And you can send it up
to your back-end.
The back-end can validate it,
like I showed earlier, and
look inside it and say, oh,
yeah, that's who this user is.
And that's the app that
he was running.
And yeah, this one
is meant for me.
You got to check these things.
And then there's all sorts
of rules for doing that.
And then you can just go ahead
and assume that the data
that's coming in is
from that user.
And you can feel free to
persist it for them,
manipulate it for
them, and so on.
Actually, I have a demo
of that working.
It depends on maybe getting
a mobile signal in here.
But let's give it a try.
It's the same Favorite
Color app.
So I'll say, well, I want
to log in at this thing.
And I'm going to click OK.
And it's trying to make
a network connection.
Maybe that was too
much to ask for.
That was a 5G.
What's the password?
So remember, I just set that
to blue a minute ago?
And it didn't prompt me, didn't
interrupt me, it just
went, and that's two pieces of
the same logical app acting
together without pestering
the user.
And I could change it and make
it a garish red, and pop.
If I went back to the website,
it would now be red.
I need to go back
to Chromebook.
And the last thing I wanted to
talk about was this permanent
offline access.
This is a thing when I describe
to developers is
making them really happy.
It's worth three unicorns
and rainbows.
The notion here is--
remember that example I told you
earlier where I want to go
and review this thumbnail for
a particular video clip?
Well, a more realistic scenario
is that people are
uploading video clips all the
time into my Google Drive.
And I want to have my back-end
running all the time,
processing them as they come
in, retrieving them from
Google Drive, computing
statistics, computing
thumbnails, pushing them
back into Google Drive.
And I want them to do this
all on my behalf.
The thing is, because I'm a
modern person, I don't even
have a web interface.
All the access is through
my mobile app.
So we've got to set up now so
you can, on your mobile app,
make a particular API call.
As usual, I'll always be
prompted in this case saying,
is it OK to authorize
this offline stuff?
And if you say yes, it will
return to your mobile app a
special code that you can
send to the back-end.
And the back-end can use it
to get a refresh token.
And then the back-end can be
working on your behalf as you,
24 by 7 by 365, until the user
explicitly revokes it.
Just about every developer
I talked about this to--
oh, yeah.
I could use that.
It's really pretty slick.
Another thing I want to
talk about is this
whole notion of accounts.
And one thing you'll find out
if you look in the Developer
Cookbook is the notion of a
Google account is quite a bit
fuzzier than you might
have thought.
For example, here's something I
didn't know until I started
working on this.
If you have a Google account,
that does not necessarily mean
you have a Gmail.
It is perfectly possible to
have a Google account
identified by a Yahoo address
or a Hotmail address.
And it turns out that huge
number of people do,
particularly a huge number of
our AdWords customers who
signed up for that with their
Yahoo address or whatever.
So in your code, I have seen
people say that, oh, well, if
they have an account, then
they give me their email
address, well, I can just use
Gmail to validate that.
Wrong.
So be careful about that.
The last thing I wanted to say
about accounts is that almost
everything I've said
here today has to
do with Google accounts.
And most of the things we're
talking about are limited to
Google accounts.
It turns out that on a specific
case of Android, you
are not actually limited to
working with Google accounts.
It turns out in the Android
account manager, you can store
accounts from other
applications.
Here's the screens from a couple
of my Android devices
showing that I've got Dropbox
and Facebook and Google and
Skype and Kobo and WhatsApp and
Yahoo accounts on there.
And it turns out that not only
can you store them in the
account manager, there's a
pluggable authenticator system
so that you can actually arrange
to do authentication
and signing people on if they
write some fairly advanced
code to do that.
But the Android platform, as
it comes, is genuinely
identity, fairly neutral.
Well, there are some things that
are built-in for Google.
That's all I'm really going
to say for myself.
I thought I should come back
to where I started and talk
about the other talks that
are going on here.
I think, it may be more obvious
now by the seven
different Google+ talks.
Obviously, some of them
are specific.
So if you're an Android
developer, an iOS developer,
or something, and you're
interested in Google+ Sign-In,
go to that talk.
The best practices, I think,
is going to be a
good talk for anybody.
And I suspect that most people
who are using Google+ Sign-In
are going to be using it
alongside Facebook and Twitter
and so on and so forth.
So there's some practical
advice there how
you might do that.
And the cloud guys, the "Keys
to the Kingdom" talk there,
the cloud guys have found out
that there are all sorts of
weird corner cases and gotchas
and so on that when you're
deploying identity in the cloud,
because you're doing
both the server side and the
client side there and so on,
and they actually found
enough that they did a
whole talk about it.
So if you're going to be doing
that, I would strongly
recommend taking in that one.
So I'm about finished.
I think I've tried to bring
three messages here.
The first being please stop
making people type passwords.
Use OAuth.
Use OpenID.
Get out of making people
type passwords.
It's cruel, unusual
punishment.
Secondly, there are a lot
of libraries out there.
They're pretty good.
They are available for your
programming languages.
Use them.
We want not only a good user
experience, but a good
developer experience.
I will acknowledge that in
the history of identity
technologies, we have not put
enough work into developer
experience.
We are putting a lot of
work into it now.
Have a look at it.
I think you will find it's
easier than you think to do
the right thing.
The final thing I want to leave
you with is please,
please, please get out of
the password business.
The internet can't afford it.
The course we are on now is at
a very high speed heading
straight for a brick wall.
At some point, large numbers of
people are simply going to
start refusing to go to new
sites because they don't want
to deal with the pain
of making a new
account and a new password.
We know this at Google because
it's already happening.
At Google, when somebody wants
something, we want them to go
to Google and search for it.
And a lot of times,
they don't.
They go straight to some
particular online store or
something because they don't
want to deal with the pain of
getting signed in to a
new site if they find
it somewhere else.
And that could be your site
they're not going to find
because they didn't go to
Google to search because
they're afraid of having
to sign in.
So if we can start to work
together to create an
expectation that, in the vast
majority of cases, getting
access to a new site is a matter
of one or two clicks,
everybody wins.
So let's go there.
Thank you, kindly.
We got two minutes
for questions.
But you know what?
I really hate taking questions
from the stage.
What you can do, if somebody
wants to ask a
question, go ahead.
But as soon as I leave here,
I'm going to go up to the
Knowledge Booth, the
office-hours booth, which is
at the third floor
at that corner.
I'm going to go stand there.
And I will cheerfully talk to
people about identity stuff
until I fall over or
you guys get bored,
whichever comes first.
Having said that, does anybody
want to squeeze one question
until the last two minutes?
Yeah?
Go to the mic.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So one of the biggest problems
that I see with having these
third-party identity providers
is that a user arrives at the
site and they may be a repeat
user, but they may not
remember which identity
provider they
used the last time.
They might end up with two
accounts or three accounts or
five accounts.
What is the best scenario
for that?
TIM BRAY: Yeah, I mean,
that situation
absolutely can happen.
And it's even worse than that
because somebody may have
logged in with their Gmail
account, then they actually go
and hit Facebook.
And it comes in with the same
Gmail account because Facebook
will cert a Gmail account.
At the end of the day, we're
actually working on some
software to deal with that.
But we haven't released
it yet.
But at the end of the day,
you're going to have to do
some management code.
You're going to have to decide
when the same email comes in
from two IDPs, are you going
to regard that as
two accounts or one?
It's tedious.
It's not rocket science.
But it is some tedious work
you have to handle.
AUDIENCE: Can you assume that
the email address has been
verified by any IDP who--
TIM BRAY: That's actually--
AUDIENCE: --issues it?
TIM BRAY: --built into
the protocol.
And if you've logged in with
OpenID Connect, there's
actually a field
in there saying
whether it's been verified.
AUDIENCE: Education, children
under the age of 13, and
within the Google Play
apps infrastructure,
how does that work?
TIM BRAY: It's a big problem.
At the moment.
Google+ does not accept accounts
from people under 13.
In fact, I don't even think
you're allowed to have a Gmail
if you're under 13.
I hate to say this, but the only
company that I know of
who's doing a really
good job with
handling children is Yahoo.
Yahoo does it better
than anybody else.
And they have this thing where
you have to identify a
responsible adult.
And they have to be identified
by having a credit card, which
actually tends to work
pretty well.
The problem is--
particularly, in the United
States, in various
jurisdictions-- there are
extremely draconian bodies of
legislation, which by
the way I support.
They're quite sensible.
In the States, it's called
COPPA, Children Online Privacy
Protection Act, or something
like that.
And it's really, really hard to
stay on the right side of
that law if you're doing this.
So, yeah, it's a problem.
We acknowledge it.
But I think it's going
to go on being a
problem for a while.
AUDIENCE: Anyone knows
about workarounds?
Or how to actually--
TIM BRAY: Well, you
can always lie.
AUDIENCE: That's identity
for you.
TIM BRAY: Thanks.
Anybody who want to talk about
this, I'll see you upstairs.
[APPLAUSE]